ينتشر على الاراضي اللبنانيه 12 مخيما
رسميا لاسكان اللاجئين الفلسطينيين في
البلاد اكبرها من حيث المساحه وعدد السكان
مخيم عين الحلوه الواقع جنوب الشرقي مدينه
صيدا الساحليه
يبعد قرابه ثلاثه كيلومترات عن صيدا
وقرابه 67 كيلومترا عن الحدود مع الاراضي
الفلسطينيه يسميه اللاجئون الفلسطينيون في
لبنان عاصمه الشتات الفلسطيني اسسه الصليب
الاحمر الدولي عام
1948 لايواء اللاجئين من مدن شمال فلسطين
تغيب الارقام الرسميه لعدد سكانه تشير
تقديرات لوجود قرابه 70 الف نسمه في
المخيم
وقدرت الاونروا عددهم بنحو
48,000 عام 2019
بينما تشير تقديرات اخرى الى ان عدد سكانه
يقترب من 54 الفا جميعهم يعيشون على مساحه
لا تتجاوز كيلو مترا مربعا واحدا
يشترك مخيم عين الحلوه مع جميع مخيمات
اللاجئين الفلسطينيين في لبنان بترد بالغ
للبنيه التحتيه وغيابها في كثير من
الاحيان غياب الخدمات الصحيه الملائمه
والكافيه لاعداد اللاجئين تدني المستوى
التعليمي للسكان حيث تنشط فقط مدارس تابعه
لوكاله الاونروا منع دخول اي مواد بناء
رغم تهلك المنازل ويمنع على اللاجئين
الفلسطينيين اصلا تملك اي منزل او عقار
كما يمنعون من اي حقوق مدنيه او اجتماعيه
ومن العمل خارج المخيمات بعشرات المهن
والاختصاصات بينما ترتفع نصب البطاله داخل
هذه المخيمات
يتولى الجيش اللبناني الامني عند جميع
مداخل مخيمات اللاجئين الفلسطينيين في
لبنان دون الدخول اليها بينما تعمل
الفصائل الفلسطينيه في الداخل
تتشعب الخريطه السياسيه لهذه الفصائل في
عين الحلوه تمتلك حركه فتح تنظيما واسعا
في المخيم وما يعرف بالتيار الاصلاحي في
الحركه بقياده محمد عيسى الملقب باللينو
والمحسوب على القيادي السابق في فتح محمد
دحلان وتوجد ايضا الجبهه الشعبيه لتحرير
فلسطين والجبهه الشعبيه القياده العامه
وحضور وازن لحركتي حماس والجهاد الاسلامي
كما شهد المخيم خلال العقدين الاخيرين
نموا لحركات تصف نفسها بانها حركات
اسلاميه بعضها تم حله وبعضها الاخر ما زال
مستمرا